president biden says america needs his
agenda but democrats can't even agree on
it nancy pelosi struggling once again to
get her party on board and she says she
hopes to pass infrastructure today and
that's even after biden begged democrats
to do it
i'm asking every house member
member of the house of representatives
to vote yes on both these bills right
now
send the infrastructure bill to my desk
send the bill back better build of the
senate
and liberals are ramping up the
intimidation tactics on those who want
to pump the brakes like joe manchin
answered why won't you fight for me no
mansion is it worth it
is the money worth it
is the money that important joe mansion
is it more important than my life joe
mansion is it more important than your
kid's life
[Applause]
mansion is jesse driving a maserati and
living on a boat why isn't he a
republican just get on with it already
on over joe it's nicer on this side the
democratic leadership is very old again
and the older you get the more stubborn
you get you're laughing because you're
not even 30 lawrence but you'll get to
where we are soon joe biden's so old he
proposed to his wife eight times before
she said yes nancy's 81 have you ever
met an 81 year old who changed their
mind about anything mansion's old too
he's sitting in that maserati as it gets
mobbed you could see his blood was
boiling that's going to make him go in
the other direction pistol pete probably
would have put the pedal to the metal
and just squashed those climates
he showed some self-restraint but here's
the other thing with mansion mansion has
money on the lawn in west virginia his
entire portfolio is coal he's got
millions in coal his family's got a coal
brokerage firm you take the politics and
you take the policy out do you think joe
manchin's going to vote for the green
new deal in this bill
it's going to destroy his entire bank
account not to mention the entire bank
account of west virginia so there's no
way he's putting a yes vote on this
nancy pelosi is going to retire probably
in 2022 when they lose the house so the
gavel's toast in just nine months or
whatever she knows this she's going to
europe next week she's going to jam this
thing through do you guys remember how
they did
obamacare
the corn husker kickback the louisiana
purchase
they just start bribing congressmen and
senators that's what nancy's been doing
this whole last week
bribing these holdouts with pharma money
you know they do this salt taffy bribe
for all these new england congressmen
that's all that's happening they'll just
bribe it to death and jam it through
come on they get rid of they reintroduce
the salt deduction you're on board i
already said i'm on board with salt
lawrence
um
i'm siding with the progressives on this
and i'm gonna tell you why the
progressives didn't change
uh they are in line with the new
democratic party they were promised
things on the campaign trail even though
joe biden said he was a moderate the
policies that he was putting out were
consistent with the progressive caucus
um you got manchin who is a squish when
it comes to the democrats i think the
progressives should hold the line and by
the way nancy pelosi and the leadership
should stop doing press conferences they
keep saying that they have recent
agreement they have not reached the
agreement
they have lost voter turnout part of the
and we talked about this before we got
on the the progressive bin on this is
that they didn't lose this election that
the the turnout was so low is because
they didn't deliver on what they said
they were going to deliver to the
american people and quite frankly i
agree with them now i think they're bad
you know what crazy but at the end of
the day if you tell your electorate that
you're going to do something and you
don't do it you should be held
accountable yes
well since lawrence is playing
progressive today i guess i can i can
hang in the moderate wing
i think that they should pass
infrastructure as fast as possible and
frankly should have done it six weeks
ago when they got the go-ahead from the
senate and that's something that's
hugely popular with the american public
they had what seven eight republican
senators on board it's a win for
everybody infrastructure always works
that way and then everyone has something
to go into the midterms with so we have
the american rescue plan plus
infrastructure republicans will have
infrastructure um i don't know when this
gets passed probably next week that it
goes through because the progressive
caucus wants them to come together but
to lawrence's point about our previous
conversation i i think it is really
important when a party is taking two
different lessons from an election
outcome you're going to end up with a
lot of fissures in the immediate
aftermath because there are a lot of
moderate democrats that are very worried
about their midterm fates because of
what they saw in virginia that new
jersey was obviously closer than it
should have been even though phil murphy
pulled off an incredible feat no one no
democrat has been reelected since 1977
to the governorship and all of this also
takes away from being able to talk about
very real accomplishments like today's
jobs report 531 000 jobs added august
and september revised up 4.8
unemployment rate 5 million jobs added
in total dow all-time highs these are
things that democrats need to be focused
on and not the inciting all right 4.6
unemployment rate because it fell um
one-tenth over a percent so that that's
even better notice but on that note
mr hegg seth biden today said we need
these bills to put the pandemic behind
us
the pandemic is over this is this
evidence on the economy we're coming out
of this the economy is growing pandemic
over and also as evidence by the last
week um when he was campaigning for
terry mcauliffe he was armpit to armpit
with people in like a liberal mosh pit
no mask anywhere pandemic is over that's
that's a garbage way they're attempting
to sell it i think the bigger dynamic
here is what happened in virginia and
new jersey and jess you mentioned the
cornhusker kickback in the louisiana
purchase how many members of congress
that were a part of those deals are
still members of congress
because eventually it comes back to you
yeah and so it's it's uh gothheimer and
the others in the moderate wing of the
democrat party they're saying hey how
about we hold out 72 hours so we can
read the 2 000 page socialist bill that
doesn't even have a cbo score right now
because nancy wants yet again to pass
the bill so that we can all find out
what's in it we have no idea what's in
it they know it they're breaking
we're going to go back to norms in the
house of representatives right they've
held the vote open longer than any other
vote before there's no regular order at
all she's jamming this through they say
it's going to reduce the deficit right i
mean the wall street journal is pointing
out today it's actually a four trillion
dollar bill and that infrastructure bill
that the left loves so much if only
there was some infrastructure in there
because most of it's human
infrastructure there no
most republicans are not voting for that
one
most republicans are not going to vote
for that bill because they recognize
what it really is a precursor to the
green new deal
you call nancy pelosi a master
legislator with all of this chaos
happening
the progressives just kicked her out of
their meeting last week so
you just wait well and then medicare
medicare hospital trust fund runs out of
money in less than five years and you're
gonna get a nine percent uh benefit
decrease what about that hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else